welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and as marvel spider-man 3
continues production
one huge question that the films haven't
really addressed but we are looking to
get some answers on
is the matter of this version of peter
parker's origin story
how did tom holland peter parker become
the underoos spider ling
i mean we know the basic gist
radioactive spider bite yeah yeah yeah
but you know after seeing that twice and
two other spider verses three if you're
counting miles morales
marvel studios elected to introduce
their peter parker already in the throes
of superheroics by the time tony stark
recruited him to
team iron man in the civil war event
well a new detail has just been
confirmed about peter's past
in the mcu timeline making it seem even
more likely that this third marvel
spider-man film could address
this history in a way that could be
important in the way the film might
cross over
elements from past spider verses with
tobey maguire and andrew garfield
if that ends up happening and i think i
just discovered a huge new detail in
spider-man homecoming i'm gonna break
down everything i've learned spoiler
warning in case i am right and uh that
ruins your life
okay so when we first met tom holland
peter parker in captain america civil
war his bio was a bit
spotty climbing walls how are you doing
that adhesive gloves
it's a long story i was lordy can you
even see
in these yes yes i can't look i can't
i can't i can't see in those okay it's
just that
when whatever happened happened it's
like my senses have been dialed to 11.
they just kind of helped me focus peter
goes on to say that he has had these
powers for six months
then in homecoming peter chatted with
ned about his spider bite
you got bit by a spider can you bite me
well it probably would have hurt right
you know what whatever even if it did
hurt i'll let it bite me
maybe how much did spiders dead ned
shortly after that tom holland and kevin
feige retconned a detail all the way
back in iron man 2 confirming that the
boy
in the iron man mask that tony stark
saves at the expo fairgrounds was a
young peter parker
actually if you re-watch iron man 2 that
kid actually shows up way earlier when
tony gets mobbed by fans at the
fairgrounds but homecoming seems to tie
in this retcon by showing peter's phone
video recording the queen's world's fair
sphere
suggesting he is remembering that event
but presumably the historic spider bite
happened between that iron man 2 event
and tony's apparent reunion with peter
in civil war
there was a reference to that bite in an
alternate version of iron man nick
fury's post-credits scene
as if gamma accidents radioactive bug
bites and assorted mutants weren't
enough
and right before civil war there was a
line in ant-man
interpreted as a nod to spider-man's
arrival to this world
well we got everything nowadays we got a
guy who jumps we got a guy who swings we
got a guy who crawls up the walls you
gotta be more specific
and we also got confirmation that there
was an uncle ben
to peter in this universe with a
close-up of his suitcase apart from home
revealing the initials bfp
for ben [ __ ] parker or if you're lame
ben franklin parker the presumed middle
name for the character but the recent
new detail came up in
this mcu book that we've been talking
about the wakanda files
shuri's collection of journal entries
related to weaponry and technology in
the universe
in a section titled tony stark personal
log tony writes how he tracked down
peter parker through peter's youtube
channel which we did see a little of in
homecoming with one post talking about
peter's experience being bitten by a
radioactive spider and gaining
superhuman strength tony goes on to
wonder about his web shooters and where
they came from so what do we know about
peter as a youtuber well if you look
closely at a shot in homecoming peter
does watch the clip
of that same bus save that tony showed
him in civil war
it was uploaded by the account name
rocket robinson 67 but you know based on
the fact that someone must have been
recording this
video from a handheld phone camera while
peter was
in the video and at that time no one
knew peter was spider-man and peter
would not want this footage out in the
world i doubt rocket robinson 67 is
peter
but peter did tell tony back then that
this exact video was
fake because you know that's all fake
it's all done on the computer and if you
look
in the comments beneath this bus video
the top comment comes from it looks like
an account name like two bits two
something
54. who comments fake exclamation point
explanation
exclamation point one i think that
commenter
could be peter's account and that could
be how tony tracked him down
and that is why peter is watching this
particular video after tony found him in
civil war
based on new clues we are seeing from
the spider-man 3 set
i think this next movie will revisit
these early years but before we continue
this video was brought to you by
audible and their unmatched selection of
audio products audible just
launched their newest plan audible plus
and with it you will get access to the
plus catalog
filled with thousands of originals
audiobooks and podcasts
including exclusive series like heist
with michael kane
or a grown-up guide to dinosaurs best of
both worlds there
and if the mandalorian isn't enough to
scratch your star wars universe itch
audible has a big star wars collection
including star wars
ahsoka narrated by clone wars voice
actor ashley eckstein
and if you're not in the mood for a
galaxy far far away they got the goods
from stephen king agatha christie jrr
tolkien and all the other literary
heavyweights audible plus connects you
to tons of content whether it's comedy
fantasy true crime science fiction or
fitness and wellness
you can even squeeze in a workout or
guided meditation without having to go
to a gym
or a class now the audible app is free
and can be installed on all smartphones
and tablets and you can listen across
devices like amazon alexa enable devices
without losing your spot that's pretty
cool
now is the best time to try audible plus
with the holiday offer it's only 4.95 a
month for your first six months
after your first six months it's still
only 7.95 a month to download and stream
thousands of all you can listen
audiobooks originals and podcasts
included in the audible plus
plan so now is the time to try audible
plus just go to audible.com
new rockstars or text new rock stars to
500
500 and with the holiday offer it is
only 4.95 a month for your first six
months again that's audible.com
or text new rockstars 2 500 500. okay so
again the big question we still don't
really know about this peter parker is
exactly what went down with his uncle
ben
and the full events of how he got his
spider bite i think the third spider-man
film currently in production has a great
opportunity to fill in this history
especially with speculation that doctor
strange is joining this plot we could be
looking at a kind of multiverse
spider-verse crossover with people like
toby mcguire or andrew garfield
returning again still not confirmed if
you remember toby maguire peter parker
was bitten by a genetically modified
spider on a field trip by
accident due to him getting a little too
thirsty snapping glamour shots of mary
jane
andrew garfield's peter parker though
deep in that mythology by making that
spider come from the lab of oz corp
a total conspiracy tying in the research
of peter's father
hinting that peter might have been
destined to become spider-man
now the tom holland version hasn't gone
into it yet but it seems like it is
swinging back toward the toby direction
based off what he told ned it seemed
like a one-time random event but
also sticking closer to the more
canonically true andrew garfield version
in which peter
builds his own web shooters and wet
fluid as opposed to you know it coming
out of weird organic glands in his
wrists now
after homecoming came out in 2017 tom
holland joked that he wanted tobe
mcguire to play the mcu version of uncle
ben
and now that maguire is being rumored to
make a cameo in this third encu film
many have been spinning theories
suggesting the mcu uncle ben could
be played by maguire but will be a
separate character then maguire is an
alternate universe peter parker but that
the two men just look exactly alike
which i guess will lead to some
what head turning i don't know about
that but recently i explored tom
holland's first look image confirmed
from the spider-man 3 set
and talked about that mystery hand
visible on the right side of frame
i pointed out how the sleeve hangs down
over the knuckles
which many of you have since pointed out
matches almost exactly the sleeves of
andrew garfield spider-man from his film
garfield could be standing right beside
holland spider-man here and that set
that they're on right there
with the blue screen industrial floor
fan they could be in an interdimensional
cross stream the web of life and destiny
where doctor strange could help these
alternate peter parkers meet
and cross paths and help each other good
ned eyeball void
it is still way too early to know any of
this stuff but i bring it up because one
thing we know about sony the studio
taking the lead on storytelling with
consultation for marvel is that
sony seems pretty dead set on working
in plot points from their past fighter
verses into
the next spider-verse their reboots are
never complete clean slate resets
they kind of just do what they were
always gonna do like take dr connors the
lizard he was chosen as the villain for
the rebooted amazing spider-man
after he was set up as a villain by sam
raimi in his spider-man two and three
similarly vulture was the villain in
homecoming after raymie planned for
vulture in a fourth toby maguire
spider-man movie that never happened and
now we're seeing that with jamie foxx
electro coming to the mcu spider-man 3
from the amazing spider-man 2
apparently never truly dead in sony's
eyes
so all of that stuff with oscorp being
behind peter's fighter bite the sinister
six plans
yeah i think that could end up being the
case for tom hall and peter parker's
origin story and future
in the next film that could be what
andrew garfield peter parker helps him
understand
and while i would hope we don't see
exactly the version of harry osborne
goblin we got in that film
yikes i think we are all eager for
oscorp to be established in the mcu
somehow
this could be it if you want to help
support this channel check out our merch
store at newrockstarsmerch.com
we got a bunch of stylish gift options
you will love subscribe to the rockstars
hit that notification bell
follow me at eavos follow new rockstars
see you next time and uh may that time
be
a pizza one pizza time
[Music]
so
you